Final Fantasy 15 took a decade to  develop but those ten years of expenses  are already covered I'm Tony and this is  your money-making gamespot news update  in an interview with dual shockers  director Hajime Tabata said that Final  Fantasy 15 broke even on development  costs on day one the game shipped five  million copies on its first day and it  hits six million in January before  launch Tabata said the game would need  to sell ten million copies to meet  Square Enix's goals though that's not  necessarily when it would turn a profit  especially when you consider marketing  costs Final Fantasy 15 received an 8 out  of 10 from GameSpot and there's a lot to  discover in the game no matter which  difficulty you play on speaking of which  you can catch our discussion on games  that are best on the hardest difficulty  that's on the lobby gamespot's weekly  live show every wednesday at 11am  pacific for everything else you're  already in the right place